his Royal Rift has just been this
fascinating topic for so many people and
you write in your book that you say that
William hasn't been able to forgive
Harry stepping back for numerous reasons
so now that William is taking on these
additional roles and responsibilities
now that Charles is king and head of the
monarchy how will the Brotherhood evolve
from here moving forward now that they
are giving these new positions will we
see any sort of repairs in this Rift
between the Brotherhood well I think
everyone wants to see a repair in the
rift because it doesn't do anyone any
good to have this rift at the heart of
the House of Windsor you know I know
that as much as as the King has got big
issues and they are big issues the
Commonwealth keeping the kingdom United
I mean that's what keeps him up at night
but he also has this familial riff that
is overshadowing the start of his ring
because it is generating headlines it is
generating talking points and it is
certainly something that he's going to
need to sort out in the process of
writing this book I really wanted to get
to the bottom as to whether there could
be a Reconciliation and I spoke to AIDS
past and present including one very
senior aide who'd worked with the
brothers for a good 10 years who knows
them both and still speaks to them both
and actually he was surprisingly
confident that there can be our
approachment but it is going to be some
time down the line and that is largely
down to the fact that William simply
cannot forgive Harry not just for
leaving but for how he left
foreign